gemischte Familiennamen oder Gulasch
Namen wie es bei Bild getauft haben denn
wenn es nach den Grünen geht dann können
Paare ihre Nachnamen bald miteinander
verschmelzen das nennt sich mashing also
aus Olaf Scholz und Friedrich Merz wird
so Herr und Herr Schmerz aus Uwe
Ochsenknecht und Kathi Karrenbauer
könnte so auch leicht Herr und Frau
Ochsenkarren werden das klingt
wahrscheinlich nicht nur für sie wie ein
Joke sondern auch für mich aber in
Großbritannien ist das bereits Praxis
und der grüne Rechtsexperte Helge
Limburg ja der würde eine Verschmelzung
sehr begrüßen und ich freue mich schon
den ganzen Tag darauf diese Frage zu
stellen und zwar ein Herr Bruder mit wem
würden Sie denn gerne verschmelzen ja
mit den Titel meine natürlich das wurde
heißen oder Bruder Mann und das sind
vernünftiger dafür wenn sie leiden ja
zur Zeit in deinem unglaublichen
Magellan Probleme und da bin ich den
Grünen für jede Idee dankbar und das ist
eine typisch grüne Idee keine braucht
das es kommt nicht darauf an aber wir es
durch also sie sagen es können wir ruhig
machen ja es kommt nicht mehr darauf an
wissen sie es gibt so gruselige Gesetze
so völlig unnötige Geschichten das nennt
man das das selbstbestimmungsgesetz
nachdem ich mich einmal am Jahr einmal
im Jahr umbenennen kann von Herrn Bruder
auf Frau Bruder findet übrigens henriken
sehr schönen Vornamen da freue ich mich
schon drauf also das macht mehr oder
weniger macht da kommt es nicht
ihr Nachname wirkt ja schon wie
zusammengesetzt jetzt wird hier noch der
Bruder Mann draußen ähm ja kann man denn
ihr nachher überhaupt noch optimieren
und was halten Sie von dem Vorschlag der
Grünen also ich finde das klasse die
Grünen sollten sich nur noch mit solchen
Themen beschäftigen finde ich ja ich bin
sogar dafür dass die ein eigenes ein
eigenes Ministerium bekommen ja der
Habeck der richtete
Wirtschaftsministerium sehr viel Schaden
an für Deutschland ja und wenn man dem
jetzt zumindest geben würde für Doppel
Doppelname ja oder ich meine die Grüne
haben andere Ideen gehabt die wollte
doch den Parlament Poeten also dann
geben wir ihr das Ministerium für
parlamentspoiden und dann dem Habeck für
die Doppel Doppelnamen und wenn sie sich
dann nur noch damit beschäftigen das ist
toll für Deutschland ja ihre Ideen sind
prima schon mal alle da gewesen wenn ich
bei Monty Python der hat ja das
Ministerium für seltsame Gänge erfunden
könnte auch von den Grünen sein ja man
muss sagen als Dr dr Rainer zittelmann
können Sie auch in den Ministerium dann
wirklich gut arbeiten eigentlich wir
haben zwei Drittel dann noch eigentlich
der lange
nachnameter
jetzt mal den Spaß beiseite weil was
Herr Bremer gerade schon reingerufen
hatte stimmt ja natürlich dass die
Grünen ja mit Blick auf die Koalition
ist vielleicht sogar wirklich besser für
unser Land wäre wenn Sie eher kuriose
Ministerien hätten na ja es wäre
jedenfalls geräuschloser weil ich glaube
die allgemeine Empörung wäre hält sich
dann in Grenzen da gibt es eher so eine
Art von Kopfschütteln was das nun wieder
soll und ist das so wichtig für unser
Land dass wir nun die Namen
zusammenziehen weil das kann man ja mal
machen wir haben das auch macht in
meiner Sternzeit als wir
Titelgeschichten zu dritt geschrieben
haben Peter Neuhauser Manfred Bissinger
und Heiner Bremer daraus wurde dann
Peter breminger das kann man natürlich
machen weil da muss man nicht so viele
Namen schreiben aber das ist ein das ist
natürlich dann nur ein Kunstgriff aber
das als neue Richtschnur ich finde es
albern wie so vieles albern ist wie er
auch das gender irgendwas ist was jemand
ja machen kann wenn er Lust dran hat
aber was einem doch bitte nicht
vorgeschrieben wird wie geht's ihnen
möchten Sie das gerne dass sie Nachname
jetzt gemischt werden man hört ja
vielleicht haben sie sich ja sogar vom
Stern die Idee abgeguckt das könnt ihr
durchaus möglich sein
sowas natürlich nicht weil ich finde es
befremdlich und ich finde deshalb auch
befremdlich weil wir so ernste Themen
eigentlich momentan haben dass ich
nicht nur vom Inhalt sondern vom Timing
her bedenkt ich finde jetzt so ein Thema
aufzumachen wo doch viele Dinge so im
Augenblick muss ich dringend drum und
kümmern sollte noch die Energie drauf
verwenden auch die Debattenkultur
endlich drauf verwenden das war die
Dinge vernetzt denkt über die Ressourcen
hinweg denkt und nicht sich über
Namensgebung
unterhält und lieber sich mal auf die
wesentlichen Themen konzentrieren sollte
und das wäre so mein Appell auch in die
Kollegen die Grünen sozusagen wurden sie
abgezockt oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung das
kann ich Wahnsinn jetzt melden unsere
Reporter kümmern sich um Ihren Fall
vielen Dank
Bild kämpft für Sie